here you go Peggy as everything your
mother ordered and her ration card and
here's a locker each Necker just for you
Wow gee thanks mr. Wilson
[Music]
I'm gonna get you out get it on leave
okay good girl
[Music]
[Music]
bad girl
good nutrition is a matter of state
security wunderbar soldier who ever
lived
[Applause]
welcome back to round three now is where
it gets really exciting on America's
number one game show okay
hands on your buzzers here we go the
honor will use exercise self-control all
the joy and pain Picture Show
Oh second balcony
was the place with meat second seat got
that Street you were sweet
the old and the wake are doomed
[Music]
William I prayed for you to wake up
gotten so fat that says we're having
twins uh
Frankel she's been hunting for you she's
been moving heaven and earth and today
she found you you think you're hero
William Joseph Glasgow
foster's did this no monsters
hello
come on Peter let's go someplace else
mom no nuts
oh btw sure duck you one strawberry
milkshake please oh I hope you don't
have a fire back there to put out if so
I'll come back another time
I'm sure the fire can wait coming done
one strawberry milkshake coming right up
fireman I recognize your face very Aryan
face it is - are you at a station one
there York I'm not
Oh vielen dank mmm
now you show me your identification
papers please
not divine spirit back in the American
people
[Music]
shoot us
[Music]
just who the [ __ ] you write boy stay
calm
let me first make it absolutely clear
that I am NOT a Nazi were you saying say
your Nazi I'll [ __ ] this [ __ ]
let me say this again I ain't no goddamn
Nazi huh now you bring superfish in and
you put him down right now
I will shell this grenade so far up your
ass like I got precious little time for
your [ __ ] we've been trying to make
contact with your group we're organizing
for a revolution in America we take our
legs it's just a death oh there's gonna
sense of humor for the longest time I've
been hearing through the grapevine about
this resistance
leader
party you know my mall we said never
trust a man can't handle is whiskey so
you sit right down
cetera billion drink up
now listen tera billion I respect your
ambition but there's nothing gonna be
done no more
the world will sank into the crapper and
all we can do now is drink this whiskey
and watch the ball take suck it all down
didn't expect your belly to be quite so
yella waitin it up against the
imperialist war machine in the United
States of America and the greedy money
minute Wall Street use it 10 ascended
children of the proletariat of the dive
corn lands so that they could be filling
their coffers it weren't their sons
bleeding on the beaches I got kids on
the way and I'll be damned if I'm gonna
raise him in a world run by these not
yet you take freedom away from the
American people you're playing with fire
can I attend
see
[Music]
-
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]